[Music]
so this thing went viral on Tick Tock
when he you've been going out
when you've gone when you're going out
for six years and he still hasn't
proposed
so I'm gonna go waste a good [ __ ]
bottle of wine my G so from there
everyone's like yo sis why y'all not
married this and that so they do a
follow-up video we're at a little Sonic
date this is Derek everybody the
boyfriend that I've been dating for six
years and he still hasn't proposed
anyways Derek oh you seen the ice
you see the eyes you see the eyes on the
guy this is the I'm about to dump your
ass if you don't stop your [ __ ] go
ahead and [ __ ] around and find out [ __ ]
around and find out now you're going to
expose my [ __ ] oh I believe it
um but Derek why haven't you proposed to
me yet
because you keep asking that's why my
mama asked me to do my room I don't
[ __ ] do it but when I get up and want
to do it I do it keep asking that [ __ ] I
won't do it go ahead
what
just haven't gotten around to it yet
do you have plans to to propose to me
yeah one day hopefully
can we can we be a little serious come
on you're not angry anymore you just
trying to quit
go on edge lately
yeah oh my God whoa
oh my god oh oh my God he's a bit on
edge because I'm about to post this [ __ ]
online
foreign
and and and and you and you don't and
you don't see how that's not fine yo
listen you don't see how that's not okay
you know what I don't get I do get it I
just think it's really [ __ ] stupid
go ahead
if you're not religious your obsession
with marriage is complete fans
this you this shoe like like this shoe
like she's not talking about like being
seen before God she's just thinking
about the Romantic aspect of walking
she want to live her little Disney
princess if you're not she hasn't
mentioned God in this whole thing her
relationship with that or how it's
important to her she just says
nothing else
I could take it a little more seriously
if it came from a religious perspective
oh vanity but it's just vanity it's all
vanity so like that's why I don't take
people like this very seriously like I
don't know it's just it's so cringe
as much as I think that the people that
are doing that for Jesus or
it's a bit nut but it's your own thing
and you have your own belief so I'm not
gonna go like that's what I think that's
what I think about it but if that's you
and you do that because of that then I
get it yeah but this that's just it's
just a show and tell oh look what I got
look what I got how are you my girl
you're gonna be a whole bride as well
she looked like she 25 something like
that they've been dating for six years
which means doesn't matter it does
matter it does matter there's a giant
difference between six years when you're
40 six years when you're 35.
when you're 18 if you put it that way
hey there you go right so so it's just
like they're young
they're young okay it's okay to go
slower especially around those ages
because if you know the numbers people
under 30 who get married almost always
end up divorced
it tends to go better when you wait and
you take your time with it so all this
need to rush it's like remember when I
said like something about ladies they
love changing a dude
you know I mean they got their cardboard
cut out of their life and they take a
random dude and they be like put your
arm in there
arm right here
lean this way head tilt that way now go
[ __ ] and then if your arms say you're
happy I'm happy
how about you take off this jacket I got
a jacket that would just suit you nah
this jacket is fine no no no no no I
think I know what you should wear to
look but if you want to get married that
deeply [ __ ] why don't you propose
foreign
they don't want to initiate the romance
they want to give you the idea so that
you can initiate the romance that they
wanted in their head yeah
they don't want to have to ask you they
want to give you the clues so you can
ask them yeah I don't to me seems so
manipulative and almost like just relax
and if you're really not happy with the
timeline then
take a hike
but rushing and pressuring and doing all
this it's like yo marriage is a big deal
it's not something to be taking privacy
just because you're there doesn't mean
he is and you constantly asking everyone
you know what they said when they saw
this what oh he's an [ __ ] oh yeah it
is perfectly acceptable to pressure dude
all you want and they don't see any form
of coercion in there you've never heard
someone say this is coercive in any type
of way to constantly ask it's not like
she's asking for emotional attention or
for him to be a better boyfriend or a
better partner that's not what she's
asking she's asking for him to take one
of the biggest decisions in life before
he may even be ready and you don't and
he's numerous times people this numerous
times says I'll get them when I get
there we're not there yet give me time
and she keeps pushing now imagine you
sliding sex into this how would anyone
react if we do is doing that well if a
girl than that no for girls do that
nobody cares but if you get what I'm
trying to say okay I just want you guys
to appreciate that there's so many ways
in which women get to be openly
manipulative to coerce people to
pressure them okay all right to taking
big decisions much bigger than sex okay
nobody says nothing
I know because I see this [ __ ] all
the time where I'm like yo you so pushy
you need to be doing this and that do
not recognize how bad Blaze like
oblivious didn't even consider that they
could be doing some [ __ ] up but you're
watching it and everybody guess what
they're pretty much on her participating
on that [ __ ] and you know what the thing
is gopher stops
it never stops oh y'all think that it's
gonna stop at propose
y'all think it's gonna stop at proposed
no it never stops when are you gonna
propose when are we going to get married
when are we going to get helps when are
we going to get kids what when I get
ready it never stops
never
ever
there's always a step further
the tradition of of a marriage is that
the family of the groom
pays for it that's a tradition
Ally split half and half so of course
you're all comfortable of asking because
you're not the ones paying for it but
let's let's be honest you have a hard
time paying 50 50 on a date imagine
you're gonna pay 50 50 on a marriage no
because he's trying to give up tobacco
and nicotine
I'll give him a little break
how is it gonna be a surprise if you
keep asking me about it every day
[Music]
on the job my [ __ ] bro I ain't watch
this but yes yeah if you ask me for the
surprise it's not surprised you want a
surprise birthday party mention it once
and then don't talk about it ever again
okay but don't mention it all the time
like hey three months my birthday's
coming up April April 25th don't forget
two weeks later so what you're gonna do
for my birthday so what you're gonna do
what you gonna do what you gonna do what
you gonna do what's wrong with you what
you gonna do what you gonna do
they come for Comfort birthdays
birthdays what you gonna do what you
gonna do when they come for you para
things bad things what you gonna do stop
asking about it and it will happen it
okay I'll try my best to stop asking
about it I'm just really excited for it
to happen just stop asking about it just
do better Natalie do better okay but
really quick
tell everyone why you already feel
married to me
I feel this way too I feel this way too
share bank account we're on the same
phone plan have a house together own
companies together multiple businesses
what more do you want from me what more
do you want from me
never stops it never [ __ ] stops it
never stops it never stops it never
stops all right let's watch you think
you think oh my God it never [ __ ]
stops you thought the proposal was the
first thing no it was Facebook's account
it was it was businesses it was it was
joint account it was it never stops all
right this is the middle
wait and for those of you who don't know
me I race professionally in NASCAR
and we met racing like short track
racing locally and he quit racing to
come help me find sponsorship so I can
pursue my dream
like that's better than a ring but I
still want the ring plus the dogs are in
my name so I know she ain't going
nowhere
all right we're ending it don't let a
boyfriend stop you from meeting your
husband
his tone red flag can I ask you is her
tone not a red flag how annoying and
[ __ ] pestering she's being about this
whole thing not a red flag no women will
never see nagging in constant like
belligerent someone okay okay as a red
flag because if it's a female who's
doing it nobody cares it's never a red
flag ask 95 of men how they feel when a
woman next and they will tell you it is
one of the most disgusting behaviors a
lady can gain should to constantly do
that and I know women understand this
because in a sexual context you say you
should never pressure pressure but they
can do whatever they want hey who
doesn't
so many of you hate my boyfriend right
now and it hurts my heart because you
don't know him at all and he's seriously
the best person in this whole freaking
world he's my best friend my only friend
but you're my best friend and my lover I
will be better at not trying to be
joking all the time and
especially about series what the [ __ ]
are we watching now we're watching a man
get cucked in real time oh yeah yeah
he's simping hard and I'm all for simply
for your girl if you want to sip for
your girl but if you no but if you
simply for the internet we got a problem
oh yeah simple your girl not everyone
else
that's crazy
this man got cut by the end of the
internet said yo watch your tone Oh yeah
he came back next I'll I'll make sure
that I will not be so joking because you
guys hate me yeah whoa yeah honey you
don't realize the way this social foot
in your mouth yeah
and proposed to me and you guys
just don't know how he jokes around
opposed to this girl
you are my one and only
may look like you're reading from a
teleprompter in an Isis video bro don't
see the other side of his of his face
there's a gun right there dad there's a
gun the Taliban treats me so well
they're good
listen Mom Dad I know you guys are
people of Faith uh but let me tell you
about the one true God say that [ __ ]
Allah he's changed my life and now I'm
ready to give my head in service of his
great cause masha'allah
they'll die yeah
he's waiting to the right one so that's
what we're responding to I'm not the
right one I knew since day one and I
will propose to you when you first saw
me when I was 14 and you were 18 is that
when you knew you know
you know what I wish deep down in my
soul I wish that when she said when
you're gonna when you get married I wish
in the back of his head he's like man I
can't wait to go and get a [ __ ] from
Cindy tonight
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I need it for the money
this [ __ ] is annoying as hell I got two
more years of this ciphered as much
money and then I'll marry Cindy the
moment I break up with this [ __ ] and
I'll post it on Facebook and I'll tag
her in it and I'll say it feels so great
when you find real love oh petty petty I
wish that's that's how much that's how
detestable this woman is sabotaging this
[ __ ] annoying it as hell did she just
say uh when you saw me when you were 18
and I was yeah
but that's a whole lot of times bro come
on they're so annoying
I'm just kidding we didn't start dating
until I was 18 okay
oh
it's more I can handle
he is the one we are such we are such a
great team we work together we're with
each other 24 7. okay okay okay okay
okay this is what pisses me off why are
you trying to convince the internet
I have to say to you what I said to the
other girl
[ __ ] are you dating Instagram are you
dating Tick Tock are you in a
relationship with someone in the
metaverse the people of them why are you
trying to convince random people who
have nothing to do with your
relationship about your validity of your
relationship and why are you making your
boyfriend dragging to your [ __ ] too
you know why you know why why mental
health
this is one time where you can use that
dick this is a dead it's a problem
there's a problem
she got a bunch of videos saying how
great he is and how amazing he is this
this Mental Health
someone said something that's real true
said red flag is where this man gave up
his career so she can pursue hers and
he's been supporting her ever since and
they share everything together y'all are
too hung up on a piece of paper
if you think about it the real
commitment isn't the piece of paper or
the ring the real commitment is the
actions meaning how he gave up his
career to support hers they got all
their stuff joined together that he's
living with her that he's done all those
steps that's the real commitment you
know what this is go ahead
this is the equivalent of the love
languages
you just understand give me a ring
that's what you understand you only
understand when someone says I love you
you don't understand what someone cares
for you brings you coffee quits their
own [ __ ] career to help yours uh all
those things are no no the only thing
you understand is
that fairy thing when you're a princess
and [ __ ] that's the only thing you
understand you don't understand the rest
that he did you still want I still want
you to say I love you yeah you bring me
this you bring me that you do this for
me you do that you do that you cook you
clean you're not man I want a ring but I
still want to ring
that would be the top you think it's the
top it's never the top he looks to like
me when I'm about to put in my two weeks
notice and yet and yet months later they
still got tick tocks and they're still
working well together the way you are
beaming the whole video and he barely
cracks his smile beaming is that is that
how you see her
this whole like
Lord
good Lord absolute cringe and look maybe
you know off camera they do really well
together whatever it might be but just
from how pestering she's being about
this topic like it is very unnerving
and I I just I don't even care so much
about how they're behaving I'm just
looking at everyone else's Behavior
where they're saying the man is the
problem really
but guess what ladies that's your
privilege you guys get to be annoying
and you guys get to pester and you guys
get to coerce and emotionally manipulate
openly and nobody can that's your
privilege
desert I've accepted this uh
hey at this age when I see it I'm just
like I know what it is and I keep it
pushing but
I just wanted to point that out anything
you want to say oh no you done or is you
finished all right